PROFESSOR: An
advantage of expressing
the asymptotic notations,
in terms of limits,
is that a bunch of
their properties
then become immediately obvious.
Here's one.
If f is little o of g, or f
is asymptotically equal to g,
then, in fact, f is big o of g.
Or we can reason
about this informally
by saying that the
first one means
that f is much less than
g, and the second one
means that f is
about the same as g,
and the final one means
that f is roughly less.
So being about the same
and definitely less,
and certainly this
implies roughly less.
But we can in fact
be entirely precise
just using the definitions,
because f equals o of g
means the limit
of f over g is 0.
And f is asymptotically
equal to g means
that the limit of f over g is 1.
And the definition of
f equals big o of g
is that the limit is finite.
And clearly, if it's 0
or 1, then it's finite.
Another such property is that
if f is much less than g,
then g is not
roughly less than f.
More precisely, if f
is a little o of g,
then g is not big o of f.
The left hand side says that
the limit of f over g is 0.
But that implies that the
limit of g over f is 1 over 0,
or infinity, which
means it's not finite,
so g is not a big o of f.
PROFESSOR: Now, the
usual way that big o
is defined in the literature
doesn't mention limits at all.
And, in fact, as I said,
the definition really
isn't a limit, it's a limsup.
And let me show you the
standard definition and then
explain why the limsup soup
captures it and is needed.
So the official definition
of f is big o of g
is that there's some constant
multiplier, c, that you can
amplify g by, such that once g
is amplified by the factor c,
then, in fact, f is less
than or equal to c times g.
But this may not hold
right at the beginning.
There's a certain point, n 0,
after which it holds forever.
Let's try to illustrate
this complicated alternation
of quantifiers expression
with a diagram that
may make it clearer.
So suppose that
I want to express
the fact that f is big o of
g, where f is it a green line.
So that green line is the
graph of f of x, the function.
And g in blue is shown--
and as a matter of fact,
g of x is less than
or equal to f of x.
But nevertheless, f is
going to be big o of g,
because if you multiply
g by a constant,
it becomes sort of shifting it
up to be this constant times g.
It becomes this purple
curve, and the purple curve,
it gets to be above the green
curve, from a certain point on.
That's n 0.
So by raising up the blue
curve, g, by an amount c,
to get it to be
this purple curve,
the purple curve gets above f
from a certain point n 0 on.
And that's why f is big o of g.
Now, of course, multiplying the
blue curve, g, by a constant
doesn't raise it
up a fixed amount.
It alters it, but if we imagine
that our curve was a log
scale, than, in fact,
multiplying g by c
is the same as adding
log c on a log scale.
So the picture is
actually accurate
if the vertical
scale is logarithmic.
So using this
standard definition,
I can explain why in the
equivalent definition of terms
of limit, I couldn't say
limit, I needed to say limsup.
Here's what limsup does for us.
Suppose I have a function,
f, that's say, less than
or equal to 2g.
Which means that,
surely, f is big o of g,
according to the previous
definition, because you amplify
g by 2 and you get above f.
The problem is that f of n
over g of n may have no limits,
so I can't simply
say that f is o of g,
because the limit of
f over g is finite.
Let's see how that could happen.
Suppose that f is in fact
equal to g times a number that
varies between 1 and 2.
That's an example where
sin of n pi over 2
varies between 0,
1, and minus 1.
And you square it,
it becomes 0 or 1.
And you add 1 to it,
it becomes 1 or 2.
So this is an expression,
which as n grows, alternates
between the values 1 and 2.
And I'm multiplying
g of n by this factor
that's either 1 or 2.
But the limit of f of n
over g of n does not exist,
it's alternating
between 1 and 2.
On the other hand, the
limsup f of n over g
is 2, which is
finite, and therefore,
according to the limsup
definition, indeed f is o of g.
Now, the technical
definition of limsup
is one that you can
read in the text
or find in a calculus book.
It's basically the largest
limit point of the fraction
f of n over g of n.
And if you don't know
what a limit point is,
it's stuff that we
don't need to go into.
But I did want you to understand
why formally, we need limsup.
In most cases, the
limit exists, and we
can use the simpler limit
definition, rather than
the exists a constant, such
that for every number n
greater than or equal to
n 0, et cetera, which is
a more complicated definition.
OK.
Let's collect a couple
of more basic facts
about little o and big o
that we're going to need.
Namely, that if a
is less than b--
I know they can be
negative numbers.
I don't care, but real numbers.
If a is less than
b, then x to the a
is little o of x to the b.
The [? proof file ?]
is almost immediately
from the definitions, because
to prove that x to the a
is little o of x
to the b, we want
to look at the quotient of
x to the a over x to the b.
But, of course, the quotient
of x to the a over x to the b
is equal to 1 over
x to the b minus a.
And since a is less than
b, b minus a is positive.
So that means that as
x approaches infinity,
the denominator is x to a
positive power also goes
to infinity.
And therefore, 1 over x
to that positive power
goes to 0, which is the
definition of x to the a being
little o of x to the b.
Another crucial fact is
that logarithms grow slower
than roots.
So if you think of epsilon
as like a half or a third,
saying that the log
of x is less than
or equal to the
square root, it's
less than equal
to the cube root,
it's less than or equal to
the 50th root doesn't matter.
OK.
This is a proof that just falls
back on elementary calculus.
And I guess I've highlighted it,
because it's definitely worth
remembering.
Logarithms grow
slower than roots.
The proof begins with the
immediately obvious remark
that 1 over y is less
than or equal to y,
because they're equal
when y is greater to 1.
1 over y is equal to y when y
is greater than or equal to 1.
And as y increases, y
gets bigger, and 1 over y
gets smaller, so the
inequality is preserved.
That's easy, OK.
Well that means that I can
integrate both sides starting
at 1.
So if I take the integral
of 1 over y from 1 to z,
it's going to be less than
or equal to the integral of y
from 1 to z.
Well, integral of
1 over y is log z,
and the integral of y
to z is z square over 2.
So what we get is this new
inequality, the log of z
is less than or equal to z
squared over 2, for z greater
or equal to one.
So we're on the way there.
We've got log of z is
less than z squared,
but not z to any epsilon power.
But we'll get that just by
making a smart substitution
for z, so that's the next step.
We have that log
of z is less than
equal to z squared over
2 for any z greater than
or equal to 1.
Let's let z be the square root
of x to the delta, where delta
is simply some positive number.
So in that case,
what's the log of z?
Well the log of the square
root of x to the delta,
the square root means it's half
of log of x to the delta, which
is delta log x.
So log of z is delta
log of x over 2.
And, of course, z squared
is just x to the delta,
so z squared over 2 is
x to the delta over 2.
Now, I can just cancel
the denominators too.
And I get that
log of x, and then
transpose the delta log of
x is less than or equal to x
to the delta over delta.
But as long as delta is less
than epsilon, x to the delta
is going to be a little o
of x to the epsilon, which
means that x to the
delta times a constant,
namely 1 over delta,
is also going to be
little o of x to the epsilon.
And I've just figured out
that I've shown that log of x
is little o of x to the
epsilon as required.
One more crucial fact that
I'm going to not prove,
but I'll state is that
polynomials grow slower
than exponentials.
This is closely related
to the fact that
logs grow slower than roots.
But in particular, if
c is any constant and a
is greater than 1, then x to
the c is little o of a to the x.
And there's a bunch of ways to
prove this using a L'Hopital's
Rule, or McLaurin Series,
and I'll leave it to you
to look up your
1801 calculus text
to find a proof of that fact.